- [Voiceover] What I
want to do in this video
is think about "How does the circumference
"and how does the area of a circle change
"as we change its radius?"
And, in particular, we'll focus on
what happens when we double its radius.
Let's think about a
circle right over here.
So, this is a circle.
And let's say its radius is X units.
Whatever our units is.
This distance right over here is X.
And then let's think about another circle
that has twice the radius.
Its radius will be two X.
Let me draw its radius first
so it looks roughly accurate.
This is two X is this circle's radius.
And so this circle might
look something like that.
That's my best attempt at
freehand drawing a circle.
Let's just think about
what the circumference
of both of these are,
and what the areas of both of these are.
The circumference of any circle
is two pi times the radius.
So, in this case, the circumference,
and I'll use C for circumference,
is equal to two pi times the radius.
Which, in this case, is X.
What's the circumference here?
Once again, the circumference is equal
to two pi times the radius,
but this time the radius is two X.
So, the circumference is equal to
two times pi times two times X,
which is the same thing as
two times two times pi times X,
or we could write it as four pi X.
We see here that this circumference
is twice as large as this one.
To go from two pi X, to four pi X,
you have to multiply by two.
You double the radius,
it doubled the circumference.
What about the area?
And I'll do area in a new color.
We already know that area
is equal to pi R squared.
In this circle the radius is of length X.
It's pi times X squared.
In this circle, right over here,
the area is going to be equal to
pi times the radius squared,
but now the radius is two X.
Two X squared.
What is this going to be equal to?
Our area is equal to pi.
Two X squared is two X times two X,
which is the same thing as four X squared.
Four X squared.
Or, we could rewrite this as
area is equal to four pi X squared.
Notice, now the area has increased
not by a factor of two.
The area has increased
by a factor of four when
we doubled the radius.
Why did this happen?
I encourage you to pause the video
and think about it.
It comes straight out the formulas
for circumference and area.
Remember, circumference
is equal to two pi R,
while area...
Let me do this in a different color.
While area is equal
to pi R squared.
You see here, area is proportional
to the square of the radius.
If you double this,
you're gonna increase your
area by a factor of four.
If you triple it, if
you triple your radius,
you're gonna increase your
area by a factor of nine.
If you increase radius
by a factor of four,
you're gonna increase your area
by a factor of four squared, or 16.
While, circumference,
whatever factor you increase
you increase your radius,
the circumference is going to
increase by that same factor.
And if you don't believe me,
I mean, we essentially
showed it right here
through a little bit of algebra,
but you could try it out
with as many numbers as you see fit.